[Musique]
une société vous savez ce juge a
l'intention qu'elle porte aux plus
fragiles des siens à sa capacité à
conserver sa cohésion à son aptitude à
refuser l'exclusion d'où qu'elles
viennent
le regard que nous portons sur le
handicap révèle le regard que nous
portons sur la société tout entière
la prise en compte du handicap est
consubstantielle à l'adn de la droite ça
remonte à nos racines l'histoire du
général de gaulle du président pompidou
qui ont toujours été très préoccupé par
les situations des personnes porteuses
de handicap
jacques chirac y apporter 3 grande loi
sur le handicap
nicolas sarkozy qui a augmenté de 25%
l'allocation adulte handicapé nicolas
sarkozy s'est aussi plus d'enfants
porteurs de handicap qui ont été
scolarisés en milieu ordinaire
nous avons toujours continué à
travailler sur ce sujet parce qu'il nous
tient à coeur tout simplement
et aujourd'hui il faut encore faire une
étape supplémentaire en direction de
l'insertion et de faire en sorte que
tous les français qu'ils soient porteurs
ou non de handicap trouvent leur place
dans notre république
[Musique]
où
et la façon dont on considère les
handicapés c'est la façon dont on
considère l'humanité quand la crise a
frappé avec une violence inouïe entre
2008 et 2010 tous les spécialistes m'ont
dit il pour revenir sur votre promesse
d'augmenter l'allocation adulte
handicapé de 25 %
j'ai refusé parce que pour moi la
solidarité à l'endroit de ceux qui
vivent et qui subissent le handicap est
incontournable on ne peut pas transiger
avec 112 millions c'est le nombre de nos
concitoyens qui est touché par le
handicap 11 millions c'est le nombre de
nos concitoyens qui accompagnent un
proche en situation de handicap
plus de 20 millions des françaises et
des français sont donc concernés
directement par la question du handicap
aujourd'hui la situation est grave tous
les slogans du monde toutes les grandes
déclarations ne pourront pas masquer une
triste réalité
plus de 7000 enfants ou adultes sont
aujourd'hui obligés de s'expatrier dans
des établissements belge parce que la
france la république française est
incapable de les prendre en charge
nous avons entre 12 et 19 mille enfants
qui sont sans aucune solution de
scolarisation
aujourd'hui nous avons 19 % de nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap qui
sont frappés par le chômage et donc
l'extrême précarité
cette réalité nous devons la regarder en
face ce cri de colère là que nous avons
entendues notamment te à l'occasion de
ce grand tour de france que nous avons
pu engager ce cri de colère il est
devenu le nôtre il est un engagement à
une action forte
les enfants continuent comme ça il vient
c'est le parfait pour un tendre déjà
plaidée par ici que la reille
déscolarisés aujourd'hui c'est que
malgré ces belles phrases et sebo termes
d'inclusion
il s'avère que en réalité dans un
collège
même dans une une section ulis
quand une enfant différentes
un comportement un petit peu inadapté et
dont la pousse vers la sortie dans votre
proposition de loi les voir et good il
faudrait aujourd'hui bal
vous avez vu tant de milliards de plus
soit formé à l'origine on se retrouve
accompagner un enfant tout l'économie a
mis un handicap
vous avez suivi une formation avant de
rentrer du tout content qu elle s en
fait qu'on arrive en tant qu aves on
demande un casier vierge et après je
ferai après vous débrouiller elle arrive
on l'aimé d'anglais vous pas travailler
comme ça elles connaissent pas l'enfant
tel espace de handicap elle reste la
ramenant à vue après la repartent la
question du handicap est au coeur de
notre projet chez les républicains
je suis actuellement le seul député en
situation de handicap à l'assemblée
nationale et mon souhait c'est qu'il y
en ai plein d'autres que les personnes
handicapées n'hésite pas à s'engager
dans la vie politique parce que ce n'est
pas parce qu'on est différent des autres
on n'a pas le droit de les représenter
je souhaite aussi que notre enjeu est
notre combat majeur celui de
l'accessibilité des transports et des
lieux publics comment peut-on accepter
aujourd'hui que 97% du métro parisien
que beaucoup de gars en france soit
encore inaccessibles aux personnes
handicapées ça doit être notre combat à
tous aujourd'hui nous renouons avec
cette belle et grande histoire humaniste
de la droite républicaine
nous renouons avec cet immense défi qui
est celui de faire en sorte que notre
société demain laisse une place à
chacune et à chacun
au fond nous renouerons avec cette belle
et grande idée de la république
la proposition de loi que j'ai l'honneur
de présenter on du groupe l'est
républicain n'est pas tout à fait un
sujet comme les autres
l'école de la république la place que
l'on y fait au handicap ne sont pas des
sujets comme les autres la cause du
handicap nécessite de poser les armes de
faire résonner autre chose que les
querelles partisanes
s'il est un sujet de société qui peut
nous réunir
c'est bien la bataille à mener tous
ensemble pour les personnes handicapées
tel est le message que je veux partager
voilà plusieurs mois que les
républicains nous sommes mis au travail
sur cette question du handicap
voilà plusieurs mois que ici au siège
des républicains nous réunissent
des associations des parents des enfants
des acteurs engagés dans les questions
du handicap
voilà des mois que nous parlons aux
françaises et aux français directement
loin des salons dorés voilà des mois au
fond que la droite républicaine se place
en responsabilité elle ce matin nous
avons préparé la convention nationale en
10 capes et l'atelier que je co animé
était de tourner essentiellement vers
les questions de l'enfance de la
jeunesse et donc de l'école inclusive
c'est un vrai métier que d'accompagner
des enfants en situation de handicap à
l'école et cela passe certainement par
un véritable corps par un véritable
métier avec ce que ça veut dire en terme
de formation faut aussi bien sûr que les
professeurs des écoles que les
professeurs de collèges soit également
formés à l'accueil on ne peut pas leur
reprocher aujourd'hui de ne pas savoir
faire parce que dans la formation
aujourd'hui d'émettre par le format de
la formation des professeurs peu de
chose est prévu lors de nos tables
rondes puis écoutez le témoignage très
important et poignant des acteurs qui
sont directement liés au handicap dans
la fusion scolaire mais aussi dans les
ime tout l'intérêt de travailler
justement c'est de leur apporter la
reconnaissance qu'ils ont besoin c'est
pas évident d'être un accompagnant et en
aidant d'une personne en situation de
handicap donc si notre pays peut lui
apporter aussi un statut qui est une
sorte de reconnaissance je pense que là
le pari et les enjeux sont très
importants à nous de le relever j'étais
dans la table ronde sur les adultes et
nous avons parlé énormément de l'emploi
et de l'employabilité il faut évidemment
se donner les moyens notamment
l'accompagnement humain et en formation
et en sensibilisation pour ma part ça et
tns sofres
c'est qu'on parle beaucoup du handicap
sur le terrain c'est un sujet qui est
devenu presque médiatique où on a
beaucoup de belles phrases de grands
mots mais il n'y a pas grand chose d'eux